[Music]
you're delusional let's start there
you got your perspective welcome to
another episode of perfectly mentored
I'm your host Jason Portnoy my guest
today is uh actually if you don't know
who this man is an introduction I'm not
gonna do anything you've been living
under a rock you don't know who this guy
is
something's wrong because he's
everywhere the man the myth the legend
Gary Vaynerchuk welcome to the show
thanks for having me brother he's also
the reason by the way that we're here
right now and doing this today he was a
man that told me start a podcast and if
I do a certain amount of episodes he'd
be on so true to his word
so happy to have you on thank you so
much proud Ebro you always get the same
questions your answers are usually the
same which is a good thing it means
you're staying consistent yep but I'm
wondering how many of these questions
are just self validation questions where
they already know the answer to it a lot
is that does that trouble you at all no
I'm I don't think when you're trying to
provide value that you get to decide
what the value is that's actually giving
see people don't get it like Gary Vee
you're fooling yourself mmm look a
little bit deeper like like I have no
ambition to dictate the value that I
provide I have ambition of providing the
value the person wants so if somebody
wants to roll up and they need four
minutes of my time well I'm running to
my next meeting and I'm busy
but because nothing gets me more hyped
and like bringing humans value that they
need validation even though I know 92
percent of time that's literally what's
gonna happen in this micro moment I'm
thrilled to do it because then if they
go [ __ ] do it they start a podcast
and get an interview with me awesome but
then it goes to a next level - right
yeah you go to all these conferences I
was just had a conference where people
are talking about game-changing
life-changing conference and then people
come home and I question how many people
three months later have their lives
changed it goes back to the feeling of
people like listen to your content and
consume it they like the feeling of
being motivated but then there's work
that has to be done after it and I don't
think people like that feeling yeah and
I think that's why I talk about trying
to find things you like not making money
the variable of happiness like you know
I genuinely believe I really do
that long-term I will be far more
validated because I just really really
know that what I'm speaking about is
just tried-and-true human behavior with
an understanding of modern-day
contextual technology advancements right
so things are exaggerated right Lincoln
things of that nature and so I yeah I
mean yes I mean you know this like I
make content that's literally says stop
watching me go do it and then they go
and watch somebody else that charges
them for the information so like yeah I
mean like people what people like
consuming motivational content because
they think they're actually doing
something I think it's like watching
somebody else work out good point and so
I'm hoping that but this is why I like
to talk my truth it's the 97 times
somebody saw like the amount of people
that have hit this is why reading every
comment matters you know motivating it
is when you read a comment that says
Gary Vee I watched you for four months I
loved you then I thought you were dick
face I didn't watch you but now I'm back
and now I've been watching it for a year
and a half and just yesterday that post
with you and the barn is the reason now
I did it and I'm like [ __ ] the thing I
did in the barn I've done 874 times just
not in the barn and not with that word
and not with that meme title and it was
this time after 17 months four months of
which they thought it was a douchebag
that it was the piece of content that
actually got them to actually go to the
gym and workout I'm into it
so is it flattering if someone's like oh
yeah listen I can't listen to Kay I
can't listen to Gary anymore he just
says the same thing over and over he's
repetitive yeah why in the world would I
make up [ __ ] to like entertain you on
[ __ ] an Instagram I will never be
historically incorrect at the moment I
said it I'll never say anything I don't
believe in I will never say it I don't
need the likes I don't want the money I
don't need the admiration which is what
I really like I don't need any of that
to say something I don't believe in got
it so and another thing that you are
very clear on is is hustling working
hard hard work ethic I think hard work
matters I agree with you but there's
this whole wave I don't know if you've
seen of people coming in now he's
kidding of saying one who's [ __ ] what
no work-life balance course that you
shouldn't work work hard it's picked on
for that because the manifestation of me
believing in hard work has been you know
I say that I sleep six seven eight hours
and that nobody should do anything that
make them happy and that making $47,000
a year and being happy is amazing and
yet people want to make me the poster
child of overworking and burning
yourself out I get it I understand what
happens once you hit a certain tier I
also understand that maybe I could have
done a better job earlier in the process
of my career in creating clarification
thus I'm okay with getting Linc baited
into some of these conversations but
listen I believe in work-life balance I
just think my work-life balance is
different than yours I also think that
happiness needs to be thought about and
like when you love what you'd like this
is my hobby you also have to know what
you want right if you want to be a
billionaire you're not gonna do it by
the way let me say one more time cuz
I've got to clarify it all the [ __ ]
time I'll say for the nine thousand
[ __ ] time the pursuit of trying to
buy the New York Jets is my passion cuz
it allows me to play the game that I
love I love being a businessman the way
a lot of you love playing football the
way a lot of you love to ski the way a
lot of you love to read by the way a lot
of you love to cook watch Netflix hang
out with your friends if given the
option besides garage saleing and
watching the Jets professionally forget
about family that's on a pedestal that
nothing can touch outside of spending
time with my inner family and closest
friends and outside of garage selling
and watching the Jets there's nothing
I'd rather do then work a 15 hour day
you're self aware you know you and I
always have this why I shoveled snow and
did lemonade and I washed [ __ ] cars
as a seven-year-old all day long on
August 9th because it's what I like and
I'm not gonna judge somebody who wants
to work 9:00 to 5:00 beyond 13 [ __ ]
softball teams and play [ __ ] video
games all day and make 42k year if she
and he are pumped as [ __ ] they're equal
to me because I know a bunch of
miserable [ __ ] billionaires and I
know a lot of [ __ ] happy 55 ka years
and everything in between
so here's my thing if you listen
carefully I'm only spitting two core
things you'll be self aware and you make
yourself happy and don't let anything
other variables you are just two macro
variables and - this is what
makes me happy a lot of people are
spitting their ideology on other people
especially after they've already
accomplished something so you talk
patience to write that people should be
patient in in the pursuit of their goals
at what point does patient just become
delusion a lot of times oh so what are
the hacks or the tips that you for them
to be self-aware to know when to just
when when is patience just right we're
having the same thing for seven years
and nothing good has happened you're
delusional
let's start there that's a test I
believe in that if there's been no
progress in your rap career or in your
art or your video blog and you've been
doing it every day for seven years as
hard as you can and nothing has happened
the market has spoken that's one way now
is that four years is that two years do
people jump off like you need to see
some level of progress to keep you
having blood in the water to get you
going
but sometimes there is a breakthrough
because if the machine is in between you
and the market well then you got to be
discovered but the reason now I think
it's more pure is because SoundCloud and
Spotify and YouTube and Shopify and
Amazon now you get the feedback loop so
fast and it isn't the arbitrary
subjective call the reason that took
some of the greatest stars of all time
11 years to breakthrough is because
other people had say people didn't see
Gaga's talent they shook thought she was
weird somebody thought she wasn't weird
she breaks out but Lady Gaga today she
goes on [ __ ] YouTube and [ __ ]
Spotify direct and the market speaks
quicker people are more famous quicker
now if they have the talent because
nobody's in the middle this is why I
talk in general terms on content of
course because I don't have the context
but if somebody sat here and I listened
for 40 minutes I would tell them if
they're delusional or just impatient and
most people are impatient and delusional
there I mean that's just a reality of it
you speak to a lot of young startup
entrepreneurs that you get approached
all the time for advice but here at
Vayner you work with a lot of big
companies what can some of the young
entrepreneurs learn from the big
companies and what could be companies
learn from the young entrepreneurs
that's a great question and honestly I
would argue that that is a core strength
of mine that I play in both worlds and
so I'm able to like see the common
themes
I think big companies can learn that
process for the sake of process is the
worst thing of all time and that's all
they've become and that long-term
marathon running and building a business
is better than every 90 days but they're
stuck because they pander to Wall Street
I think startups are impatient
underestimates scale pan or to visa
you know big companies pander to Wall
Street startup spanner to be seized
neither panders to the end consumer I
genuinely believe that because I pander
to the end consumer the audience that I
am Who I am
Wine Library was what Wine Library was
vaynermedia is everybody panders two
things in the middle that mean nothing
how important is attention when you're
doing all this getting the most so if
I'm if this interview is not heard by
anybody it's not a great use of time
other than sharpening your craft right
yeah which is not horrible but like it's
better if it gets heard and the reason I
film everything is Dustin's gonna watch
this and he's gonna take a clip and if
one of them achieves 1.5 million and
views on Instagram at the moment of
scale that's a good day because we've
created more than again that's number
two that's right okay if attention
matters what yes what's going on in this
in the marketing industry right now
there's a lot of pollution a lot of
bottom feeders coming out you know I do
paid media for a lot of clients and
they're preaching that whole get spend a
dollar make ten dollars and clients are
starting to think that they need to see
attention so as yeah all clients are now
sitting there saying a dollar should
make ten dollars but they're easy but
it's crazy for me when I run ads like
for myself one X is great because if I'm
getting my money back and my marketing
content is still out there and I'm still
building a brand that's amazing how do
we clean up the market industry and and
reset the expectations that clients have
letting the market do what it always
does
do you know that everybody who picks on
me for telling people that you don't
need to make a lot there are literally
people now pushing back on my thesis
that you can be happy without making a
lot of money this is literally now
happening like watching it I'm like this
is remarkable let me explain how I plan
on addressing that by not addressing it
until the economy collapses and then
making some comments on how historically
that was so the market will course
correct and take away all the bottom
feeders and your control in this
scenario is when a client says to you
know bro I need $10 row as you're like
thank you very much I'm not the guy for
you yeah that's why I said right me too
and when the guys post that they could
get 10x I offer to hire them and then
they disappear funny how that works yeah
if you could if you could speak to every
entrepreneur in the world you're on
you're on I'm planning on it you're
hater
well with this podcast yeah if you're
standing on top of a mountain you should
have the attention of every single
entrepreneur in the world what would you
tell them real entrepreneurs or people
that are claiming to be entrepreneurs
during this era real hardworking
entrepreneurs how lucky did we get that
we didn't end up being athletes why is
that because they have to retire at 36 I
mean you just brought up something
really really good you work with a lot
of athletes
I'm just curious from your mindset I
asked Brandon signed of the same
question what are some of the common
characteristics between the most
successful athletes and most successful
business people you've met preparation
competitiveness deep passion for the
[ __ ] game I mean that's a real
entrepreneur she or he loves it so much
they couldn't be I mean my actions have
spoken long before entrepreneurship was
cool I could I was not capable of being
a student because of my deep passion for
entrepreneurship it was baseball cards
it was baseball cards that didn't allow
me to be a good student I was incapable
of sitting in class and not dreaming
about selling bo Jackson cards it took
me over but for some reason when you're
an athlete and you're missing a bunch of
school for because you're a great
athlete or when you're Beyonce being
home school right that makes sense but
not for entrepreneurs right doesn't seem
like you're allowed to miss a ton of
school if you're an unbelievable actor
actress singer athlete missing normal
school is something that all of us in
this room and listening right now
understand you're like oh yeah that's
what happens like you're the best
quarterback in the world again you got a
throw with the quarterback you miss
first class you know but not for
entrepreneurs but that's who I was used
to do baseball card shows baseball card
shows in Jersey in the 90s were Thursday
to Sunday so you pay for a table for
Thursday to Sunday but I have I had a
start Friday afternoon after school I
have to overpay for my tables and try to
make back my nut on
Friday afternoon Saturday and Sunday I'm
curious I was gonna [ __ ] miss school
on Thursday I'm curious to hear what
your answer would have been let's say
you were standing on top of the mountain
to talking to fake wannabe entrepreneurs
I would say hey gals and guys you're
about to deal with a very difficult
Scarlet Letter you live as an
entrepreneur wannabe in 2019 which means
you're propaganda on your Instagram
account is painting a life sooner than
later the economy will collapse you will
then have to go work at Chase Bank or at
you know somewhere else and you're going
to have to stop showing the facade of
being a successful entrepreneur and so
the sooner you could start telling the
truth of actually being an entrepreneur
into the process of trying to win versus
what entrepreneurship got cool super fun
for me
rappers sneakers it's been amazing I'm
super happy
I'm also unbelievably prepared for it to
be demonized the way big banks were in
2008 when the [ __ ] hits the fan and
prepared for all the comments that you
Gary you [ __ ] me up you told me
entrepreneurship now on this really cuz
you didn't listen well you make it look
easy right I don't watch LeBron play and
sit there and say oh I could be the
basketball player right I watch business
people and you're like but you're
watching LeBron you actually see it and
you don't actually see it because you
just see the byproduct at night we're
not
LeBron's [ __ ] in the weight room
right now LeBron's and cart like real
Bronx eating healthiest [ __ ] LeBron's
watching film on Ben Simmons right now
you don't see that I'm in [ __ ]
meeting 17 hours a day and my attempt to
vlog everything really doesn't work
because there's so much sensitive
information but lately I've had a couple
of these mega blogs write blogs where
people are seeing my whole day and these
are [ __ ] four to seven hour videos on
YouTube and people are [ __ ] going
crazy why I'm realizing like who the
[ __ ] wants to watch seven I mean I'm
humbled but what I realize is mmm now
they're actually starting to see certain
things like oh that's how he treats
people [ __ ] if he's doing that and he's
nice to everybody and I think I'm
somebody cuz I have 4,000 followers on
Instagram maybe I'm doing this wrong and
so yeah man when it really gets to the
Truman Show and people are really wide
somebody a little bit braver than me
shows every single thing like if I was
just if I'd have a company with clients
employees I'd show everyone just not but
I kind of sometimes dream of it because
that's what's been great about these
mega vlogs so you're gonna and you would
really see it and then it wouldn't seem
so easy you go read the client comments
on the four episodes I put up that are
long they're like [ __ ] that looks
exhausting how the [ __ ] does he have
energy to say what's up and answer the
same [ __ ] thing
have you watched one of them no have you
so what's your take on it and the
patience and the attention and the sheer
energy it takes when you have attention
yeah but I mean so you've probably get
this pushback a lot easy for Gary to say
right he's made it he's he's there easy
for Gary to say I'll do that to move on
pain I painted on your way worse I hear
fake manipulations of my story just one
more time because we're having an
on-the-record day I walked into my dad's
business doing three point eight million
dollars in sales grew it to a sixty
million dollar business
so you weren't handed it like some other
people say of course not I left it 34
years guys if I was handed a 60 million
dollar business why would I start
vaynermedia in the conference room of
Buddy Media cuz I didn't have enough
money for rent know what I did unlike
all you [ __ ] was I gave the 12 best
years of my life to my parents who I
loved the most
built them a 60 million dollar business
and walked at 34 with no [ __ ] money
now what now what dick now what so yes
people say easy for you to say that and
by the way it's what everybody does and
by the way cool fine easy because I have
talent that I'll respect but I put in
the work like you know what else is easy
being attractive you know eat you know
amazing it is if you're born beautiful
boy or girl it's let me save people time
we're on white privilege right now we're
on rich it's good to come to beautiful
because people are starting to get deep
unlike their thinking one of the great
things to happen in your life is to be a
[ __ ] smoke show
a [ __ ] male [ __ ] model gorgeous as
I always let me tell you you know I
always like this I always said if if I
could come back in life as a hot woman
yes I think I'm knowing the marketing
skills I like just so anybody
understands so they're not confused if
you were highly I'm talking like a 10
yeah
male or female your life is much better
doors open that never could have opened
it's like something doesn't you get it
you getting invited to go to Ibiza for a
week all-expense-paid everything taken
care of shopping sprees you invite it to
the fire festival yeah exactly so like
there's a ton of yeah here's my thing
I'm just not judging anybody you know
what I think is a better advantage than
[ __ ] being born into something being
born into nothing I'm on the record
remember I said it can't wait to watch
it in 20 years
the Internet the way it is today I'd
rather have zero than a hundred million
people that have zero like this [ __ ]
guy's an idiot that's cuz you don't talk
to trust fund babies I do I talk to
trust fund babies they DM me I meet them
in real life because in my business
career they're [ __ ] sad do you know
what you know what it's like to talk to
a human being that looks at you at 22
years old and says no matter what I do
no matter what I do for the next 80
years it will never be my own
accomplishment everybody will always say
I was handed it and I'm done do you know
what kind of level of depression cocaine
and partying until you die that leads to
a lot both sides are always e to come
the other side and by the way nor do I
expect anybody that grew up the way I
did in a studio apartment in Queens to
have sadness for Richard Thompson the
third they will say what I always hear
which is cool I'll cry in my Ferrari
that's cuz you don't know what crying is
dick because smiling and your [ __ ]
Toyota is way better than crying in your
Ferrari but you can stay confused and
when you get there why don't you call
good old Gary and tell me how it
actually feels crying is never
acceptable not interesting aka being sad
and depressed and not happy people
[ __ ] confused if you think a [ __ ]
Ferrari or some [ __ ] hot Supremes or
[ __ ] pretty girl or boy or a yacht is
gonna make you happy you're just not
smart about life you go do you everybody
should do whatever the [ __ ] they want
I'm one person I do not put on the
record I'm on the on the record
today I genuinely did not believe that
my points of view are more valuable than
anybody else's I've ever met
I genuinely feel that way I genuinely do
do I subconsciously understand that my
thoughts on business probably since I've
been doing it every day of my life for
the last [ __ ] 37 years
carries some weight more than somebody
who's drawn every day for 37 probably
but maybe they're just a natural talent
they see it differently like I don't get
high on my supply I enjoy sharing I
enjoy admiration I enjoy content
I enjoy humans tremendously but I'm
gonna die and nobody's gonna like I'm
gonna have a day I feel like at this
point like I'm feeling confident I'm
gonna have a good like I definitely feel
like people who have liked to share
their favorite memories I feel like I'll
have a little bit of a bad day half half
a day
like I'll trend for can be a tough
speaking gig at your funeral yeah you
know but like I genuinely think like and
then what right Prince died [ __ ] you
know like Michael Jackson died he's
people make global [ __ ] impact you
know what I mean so like but I'm but but
I'm what I don't care what anybody
thinks
and nor do I think my value on anybody
said my opinion anybody matters I do
have a yearning to communicate and so
I'll do that
welcome to listen or not I want to let
you end with just a pitch talk about
empathy wines and white I'm sorry I'm
good and going to that appreciate that
it's very kind
uh I grew up in the wine business I'm
very fascinated by direct-to-consumer
why brands I knew I had a ton of
leverage with farmers I just knew that I
could make a forty to sixty dollar wine
for twenty bucks and I was curious of
what kind of side house so that would
look like and most importantly John
Troutman and Nate Schroeder have been
with me for a decade had mins interns
came all the way up the system and I
felt like it was time to take a swing
with them as my partner's so I get to
put kids on that the Dustin's and the
Seth's who were sitting here right now
it could be like I mean I assume I'm I
don't want to speak for them but like
it's probably cool to be like knowing
you're coming in on the ground floor you
a sling cry name working we work hard
but then when you get to look at those
guys and be like they own a winery I
can't like like it's always good to sit
so why it's so pow
to see something right it's powerful to
see for me I'm sure as a kid I don't
remember seeing immigrants from the old
country make it it's powerful to see
somebody from the hood make it's
powerful to see a woman like it's why I
love amplifying stories of like all
different shapes and sizes cuz all you
need to do is see one right so it's
great it makes me happy it feels like
all that you know I ask of my people
that are in my most inner circle to work
hard to not you know you can work at
vaynermedia and get paid more you're
more than welcome but there's something
really rad if you're willing to I'm
asking them to do what I did I was 34
years old not a lot of people on earth
that I've ever built something as
quickly as I did on earth there's plenty
there built way bigger but if you take
them seven point seven billion [ __ ]
people the amount that have taken
something and grown it in seven years
the way I did for somebody else gets
real small real fast look one out of all
the things you've accomplished and
there's a lot that people admire you for
I think being this is my second time at
vaynermedia the one thing that I could
tell you as a business owner that's more
that's the most impressive out of it all
is the culture you built here of the
people that will go all-in for you and
that's just incredibly comes in one way
there is no [ __ ] drinking kool-aid
you don't trick humans you could trick
them for a few minutes but not sustained
at scale like I keep people at kool-aid
oil salesmen I'd read these comics are
like how do you not understand what 20
[ __ ] years of sustained growth means
like a 20 at 21 there's very few people
I would stay till 8:00 p.m. 9:00 p.m. to
go work for it the fact that you have an
entire office of people that's just
willing to just give you their nights
give you their weekends impressive and
the [ __ ] hundreds and hundreds of
thousands behind it that are trying to
get in Yeah right like you're like oh
you worked so hard I'm like doesn't
[ __ ] Soviet Russia and they you know
you know what the best part is in Seth
probably knows better than us about
distance have been a quick learn like I
also put them on when they don't want to
be here anymore like to me it's not like
you know it'd be oh it'd be one thing if
like sets like you know what I'm gonna
work at audible and I might go [ __ ]
yourself I would literally email the
[ __ ] CEO of audible first I'd be like
dick why don't you talk to me I would've
got you a better I would
money inaudible that would have been the
first reaction second I would have
[ __ ] liked the next thing I do like
there's a way to live life I understand
what it looks like and it's very basic
people have made [ __ ] real complicated
when you're fulfilled you can start
giving so I'm fulfilled emotionally
right the end so I'm capable to give and
there are people out there that are that
way
and I'm thankful that I'm one of them
one thing I'm concerned about is as I
get bigger people using me to make
themselves bigger the counter to my
message is money makes you happy and
people gonna fall for it look I use you
as fuel went when I first met you and I
said how would you build an agency cuz
I'm building an agency and Gary
seriously looked me in the eyes and said
I wouldn't I wouldn't build an agency
I'm like hmm okay well there goes that
that's the play - yeah and then I went
home and I'm like and it took me like a
couple of days like my wife my friends
are all like what's wrong I'm like I'm
like wow that was deflating and they're
like you're letting one guy dictate what
you're gonna do like it's not that out
of it he doesn't know you he duck he
doesn't know the context behind what you
want to do just love that I mean up out
of it and go do that's exactly right and
the point I was trying to make to you is
like oh and I got bigger and better
since then yes and and the point is like
and also look at why I said that because
I'm self-aware of what would make me
happy I Jenni dude if I buy the New York
Jets people gonna [ __ ] their pants like
it's gonna be [ __ ] Lydia outfit like
people are gonna lose like do you know
me people will go on to like if I buy
the New York Jets the amount of people
that will go on to do incredible things
will be extraordinary
cuz I'm one of the first humans because
of technology now cuz I'm special this
is what made Muhammad Ali's special
right he was calling his shots and he
used television I will be one like when
I buy the Jets in 27 years there won't
be 35 years of propaganda at scale that
I told you I was going to it'll just be
overwhelming and you know what spill
people will [ __ ] on you and sit there
and say yeah but for every person that
called that they were gonna do it I mean
everyone goes on social media calls
their shots yeah listen I feel bad for
those people like like if you live a
life of sinesses
shit's there's there's almost nothing
that the two things that are most
unattractive to me or hypocrisy and
cynicism hmm they're just not attractive
not that everybody has a little I'm
still trying to figure out how to stay
cynical to Tom Brady in the face of data
yeah so I get it
you know what I mean yeah I'm just
emotion but I'm willing to do that in
sports not real life does that make
sense yeah like like in sports your
escapism you don't want to go anything
all Pierce but do I really yeah Tommy
any money
Tom Brady wants the Vayner talent to
reprimand by the way like I and this is
why I say that yeah when Steve Ross
bought a piece of vaynermedia he offered
me a percentage of dolphins I could walk
around earth right now and people don't
you know how that is people don't know
full percentages and like I'm loud if
people think it's bigger than it was
right like three points it's in one
point like you know what I mean six
[ __ ] years ago I could be walking
around the last seven years being like
on the Jets I mean I could've cuz the
owner of the Browns I think owned a
piece of the Steelers I could have I
just hate the [ __ ] Dolphins bro but
Jets fan well it's gonna be a sad day
for all of us when you actually do buy
the Jets I mean this all this whole
thing ends Gary thank you so much really
appreciate it good job finally a place
where you don't have to hear and as many
of you know if you're watching this I've
got a Jersey potty mouth I grew up in
Jersey in the 80s and it's the way I
communicate when I first started making
content the business world I cursed at a
mid-2000s and it was stunningly
unacceptable and it probably bothered a
lot of people as time moved on and our
culture moved on like a bigger
percentage of people became okay with
some of the colorful language however a
big percentage is not everyone and more
importantly deploying empathy and caring
about the Adhan audience is
ultimately the only thing I truly
believe in I don't want to change who I
am and nor will I ever because at the
end of day I want to put my head on my
pillow and I want to be happy however I
also don't expect people to conform into
me I have to conform into them because
ultimately they're the audience for that
reason I'm super excited about having a
curse-free channel so many of you
understand that my themes actually can
help so many people that maybe don't
like the colorful language but I don't
want that to be part of the reason that
they can't consume the macro message the
real meaning and I surely don't want
anybody to fold or conform into me this
is an incredibly important chapter in my
career an unbelievably exciting channel
for me and I hope you enjoy it for the
rationale behind its creation
you